in fact a local couple both fighting
covet at the same time
at the same hospital the expectant
mother and her husband were admitted
just a day apart
and their son also suspected of being
positive well doctors recommend pregnant
women get the vaccine
the i-team's david charns tells us how
they say their faith
kept them strong as this mother shares
her battle
mama has no energy
today and it's so hard to talk from her
hospital bed
37 year old melissa deep sent this video
to her one-year-old son
dad is resting we'll see you soon
she's 26 weeks pregnant and unvaccinated
her husband timothy also at mountain
view hospital
fighting covid19 he was about to get
scheduled for vaccination but
it was too late i'm out but i'm still
having a hard time breathing
melissa now at home recovering wearing
an oxygen mask
she's having difficulty breathing while
she and her husband were in the hospital
battling the virus at the same time
doctors suspect
their son was also infected our little
boy was just
lacking a lot of energy and so what they
were saying was
he's most likely covet positive
sorry she describes her experience not
as just a physical fight
but a mental one too it's lonely
it's frustrating and it's very
humbling because there's a lot of things
that you just can't do
the couple able to hold hands in the
hospital sharing this moment
when we got to see each other it just
healed up
she credits her faith for keeping her
going now she's waiting for her husband
to come home
in the next few days it's been just so
beautiful to
to go through this with my husband it's
strengthened us as a family
and it's also definitely strengthened my
own faith journey
a journey this family soon to before
will never forget
i'm david charns 8 news now well doctors
stress there are no
known negative effects to getting the
vaccine for a mother
or her unborn child a study released in
april showed babies born to mothers
infected with the coronavirus were at a
higher risk of preterm birth or low
birth weight
the best thing to do is to talk to a
doctor